powell é conversar com você é forma mais
óbvia mas bastou a promoção desta
revolução que termine a acontecer ao
longo das últimas décadas é e
basicamente envolvendo um de algo entre
2 dois ramos do conhecimento digamos
assim é é que nunca tinham comunicado se
n 10 x e nós vimos no início logo é
inclusivamente um pequeno vídeo sobre ip
voip neurociência e foi o que nós temos
10 forma como o cérebro funciona e esse
é um dos ramos digamos assim aquilo que
nós temos vindo um ponto de janeiro
científica de se ler e ganhamos e outro
ramo têm comunicado começo é complicado
com esse problema é e todas presas e
várias vezes ao longo dos últimos
milhares de anos já tem vindo a acumular
funções acontecem assim quando jogamos
conhecimento distintos cão e conseguem é
é o sargento disse que eu estava como
sabe falar e não gostei das três armas
um carrinho sobre o que é uma componente
queria muito que presenciamos durante o
dia e uma delas logo no início e se a
sensação de ver uma opção é que nós
vamos passar mais ou menos constantes
mudanças no trabalho e na vida
particular também é posso pedir esta
opção é objetivo reuniões é muita coisa
pra fazer pouco tempo para fazer é tudo
isso
outro dos aspectos é esta noção que nós
hoje em dia temos sempre ligado digamos
assim sempre o homem irá levantar em o
braço quem já teve a oportunidade de ver
o zebu uma noção de um chefe grande nós
temos empresas como google hoje em dia
o objetivo não põe toda a informação
para um sempre propósito da estação do
word que em alguns meses atrás
dizia coisa com bom agora vai ser muito
competitivo canal pra nós somos capazes
de gerir é toda a informação vai ficar
disponível está num artigo no final do
século 18 por cento o crescimento das
muitas mensagens
vejam o quanto nós andamos um pouco
tempo depois final um grande respeito
que é bastante cara que o que eu faço
hoje em dia que é mais falar desse tipo
quiz até num contexto empresarial que
não estão nas instalações está em
constante medo presente na nossa via ea
nossa experiência
nós vamos fazer um treino tempo para
fazer nenhum teste sobre isso mas ainda
assim eu gostaria só vou colocar uma
questão e deixar a nossa consideração
seus perguntar quanto tempo tipicamente
trânsito via é conseguem trabalho
ininterrupto de um assunto
quanto tempo mais ou menos temeriam que
conseguem fazer o trabalhar falou em co
sobre isso aponta para qualquer coisa na
linha dos 11 minutos mas mais grave do
que isso é dizer que sempre que nós
efetivamente somente trade o tempo que
nós moramos até conseguimos voltar a
tarefa estava a fazer é se o chile
qualquer coisa entre os 15 e os 23
minutos
é incrível pensar que somos
interrompidas há cerca de dois minutos
sensivelmente trânsito do vih e que
moramos cerca de 15 a 23 minutos
recuperar
joão com ela e e em parte por isso que
eu acho que os níveis de stress que nós
enfrentamos hoje em dia tendem a ser um
carinho assim ipbm novas palavras ao
vento mundial de saúde
é preciso ter esse efeito assim como a
epidemia do século 21
eu acho que às vezes é como nós todos
estamos assim constante - 3 às vezes nem
no transe provar que não estou na agenda
2009 terá uma aula show mais uma
pergunta eu acho que fazer isso mais
integrada possível essas apresentações
para nós temos muitos não é muito fácil
mas quando você adquire com menos uma
vez por via passando por uma situação
estressante
sendo assim a uma questão que se coloca
que é muito importante que em tendo em
conta que nós efetivamente possamos ter
situações de estresse afeta tanto que a
nossa coluna vida que nós trabalhamos é
o que quer o fim acaba nossa vida o qual
nós possamos depender do nosso contexto
externo está aqui vai acontecer volta e
quanto é que dependendo do contexto
interno informa o próprio experience
anos e à nossa volta
eles mandaram os dois ambos já aconteceu
certamente estarei no sítio assim o meu
pai entrou no hotel ontem num
restaurante ou uma situação que
contestei favorável alegando em e ainda
assim e apesar disso
por alguma razão não sentimos assim
também porque estamos triste com ganho
chateados ou ansiosa preocupados com
alguma coisa vamos conseguir funcionar
com esta experiência de viajar pra ter
acontecido o contrário disse nós da
seleção aposta do contexto de ter um ser
difícil prova razão como por exemplo
está no trânsito e ainda assim e ainda
que apenas por breves momentos mas ainda
assim é uma seleção interna numa
tranqüila alguma maneira não aconteceu e
se nos sentimos bem ao fim ao cabo mesmo
no contexto externo difícil colocar a
questão pode ser um contexto externo tão
agradável como ficam os treinos nos
permite vai mal e às vezes não acontece
tem extrema e difícil não inclui o
incentivo do banco que eu vou matar é
que uma parte significativa do nosso e
nós possamos que nem assim o vôo
quer dizer com isso e sai uma noção
clara do que é nossa - está
constantemente a criar uma pressão de
tudo aquilo que aconteceu à nossa volta
que nós raramente temos controle sobre a
forma como isso aconteça sobre a forma
como esta obsessão que termina tudo
desde o nosso bem-estar a forma como nos
relacionamos com os outros isto aconteça
equipamentos acontece com muito pouco
control e pequenos negócios por 1 0 ao
cair mais para acontecer de vez em
quando mas não aconteça em cima
isto foi edno precisava aguardar uns
anos atrás em quase 500 recolheram é um
dado de 5 mil participantes do evento
mais de 30 países
estudo muito interessantes e três
perguntas eu tô achando que está fazendo
este ano é como é que está a sentir
estará ou não presente aquilo que está
fazendo este número e deixe com essa
pergunta
mais uma vez a dispensarem durante o
vosso dia normalmente ela queria que a
porcentagem tempo que passa um presente
e focado fazer qualquer coisa e coloque
a porcentagem tempo em que o argumento
simplesmente foge pra outra coisa
qualquer diferente daquela que estão a
fazer aquilo - vamos falar assim os
instantes mas em algumas conversas
avançaram 53 e 47 por cento do tempo que
o carro levando pra nós é coisa de 7%
tem 47% tempo que nós possamos
acumulados a nossa mesmo tendo história
vaguear pra longe daquilo que nós
efetivamente estamos a fazer
estamos a conversar há sensivelmente 10
minutos
isso quer dizer que realmente a toda a
gente está nessa sala silva ac
o primeiro é sempre foi fã mas mais
importante do que isso ainda e o nome de
tudo estou a falar que quiserem procurar
é muito recente é qualquer coisa como um
momento que vai ganhar e é uma mente
influir apontei este ponto é que nós
estamos constantemente a permitir que a
gente fugiu do nosso próprio controle
ganhos assim o resultado acaba por ser
muito positivo e é aqui que nós montamos
um carinho ao início da nossa conversa e
esta revolução digamos assim porque
precisamente porque isso aconteceu
muitas vezes porque um conjunto de
cientistas ao longo de cerca de outros
20 anos
o titular é um laboratório pessoas com
muita muita prática no dia 01 10 20 30
40 50 mil horas em nossa vida que ficar
em uma hora por dia qualquer coisa que é
um compromisso enorme no final do ano
terão 30 65 horas práticos estamos a
falar de pessoas com 10 20 30 40 50
minutos de prova de campeões olímpicos
ficaram a vida a fazer este tipo este
estranho
e aqui o que é que este estudo digamos
assim tem vindo a comprovar esta ideia é
fantástica neuroplasticidade optar por
trás do conceito da eurocidade a idéia
de que as coisas que nós prestamos
atenção e forma que nós prestamos
atenção ao mundo literalmente impacto em
alterar a forma como não sei se funciona
nós vimos numa das primeiras
apresentações gravadas do t tem cerca de
80 milhões de neurônios no cérebro e
basicamente está sempre a acontecer
enquanto vocês ouvem que eu estou
avisando enquanto olham pra este vídeo
enquanto tem pensamento sobre o que está
a acontecer diferentes entes não tem
concordo com isso não concordo com isso
está acontecendo constantemente a
acontecer estas são as últimas notícias
nós podemos encontrar em entrar muito
mudar quando já houver um só dizer sim
eu sou assim já nasce assim isso assim
não orienta todos nós jovens pessoas
dizerem isso não é bom trabalhar com
prática encontrei no mesmo quarto
pronto e é aqui que entra o papel que
evita seu entender esta palavra tem
muitas conotações é qualquer das formas
de forma que eu estava com as pessoas
pensarem habitação que é mais relevante
da nossa conversa aqui hoje
tem que ser assim com isto com o
equilíbrio ambiental fim o carro na
essência habitação isso é 16 nos permite
cultivar o momento tem duas
características do momento que está
constantemente achava e descontraída e
simultaneamento outro armamento que está
com 50 alerta e vigilância em nossa
espécie durante o dia tende a não ser
esta nós temos aqui nestes dois
estranhos a conversar com a ganhar fica
o sabor city stars o vídeo game um dos
extremos digamos assim vê muita
sonolência falta de vigilância geral da
omm alguma energia nem depois acontece o
oposto também com muita freqüência
ficamos muito preocupados com qualquer
coisa e pensamos por aqui uma vez e
outra e outra e outra e outra e não
consigo desligar digamos assim
esse seria o outro oposto momento muito
agitada e que o texto vai permitindo
encontrar este equilíbrio está
profundamente rocha e descontrair e
simultaneamente fundamental é ter
vigilantes está em vantagem nos permite
um primeiro passo e simplesmente
o que vai acontecendo dentro 9 então com
quase todos vocês eu vou arriscar que é
uma vozinha está a acompanhar esta
apresentação enquanto vou falando
enquanto vênus light uma vozinha dizendo
que sim nem nós raramente estamos com
cheiros que essa vozinha existe
raramente temos a capacidade de jim e
nem sequer me interessando foi dele o
passe da primeira de notar essa paisagem
interna e depois com esforço com treino
começar a gerir essa paisagem é
importante que eu tô 10 não é todo só
minha opinião é simplesmente um conjunto
de resultados tem vindo a ser validadas
científicamente como dizia o meu últimas
décadas
e eu só elencar rapidamente alguns
benefícios têm sido validados e um dos
primeiros têm que ver com esta ideia da
tensão e média tensão e simplesmente com
a capacidade de nos concentrarmos sem
ser na base do esforço ou sem ser é um
processo que exige bastante que
tipicamente falou que nós nos
concentramos quando vamos focar nos em
álbum veio até minha testa
nós ficamos com esforço para tentar mas
e água e que essas práticas nos permitem
a capacidade do rosário - vamos treinar
o objeto é preciso ficar lá concentrado
eu evitar o multitasking também
benefícios em termos de auxílio de uma
forma muito abrangente da nossa
capacidade e sensíveis criativas
velocidade o time usará o filme acaba
decisões que nós vamos tomando a
capacidade de inverter digamos assim o
enviesamento negativo naturalmente nós
nós temos que nos faz lutar muito mais
aquilo que acontece negativo na nossa
vida que o contexto positivo em conjunto
têm para 109 curto prazo para longo
prazo de validade e nos sonhos e emoções
é outro deste tópico que tem também se
intitulava e portanto a capacidade
simplesmente nós desenvolvemos esta
nacional sua consciência está na base do
quinto dedo à semifinal e considerado
nos meio jurídicos do nosso primeiro
temos que lutar o que está a acontecer
para que possamos gerir o primeiro a
tomar consciência e depois naturalmente
claro que o pai da guarda da manhã forma
com nosso time
nós e os outros à nossa volta enfrentei
que entrou com a empatia de conseguir as
emoções do show estão à minha volta
estamos preocupados foi street alas
ansiosas porque saúde e finalmente os
três também
e então o que nós temos vindo a ver é
que há duas opções concorrendo com mais
e mais treinamento e em primeiro lugar
esta noção devemos ter esse nível base
ensinar mais ou menos natural vai
baixando e conjuntos praticando
nós partimos sempre que encontramos uma
situação estressante todos nós
encontraremos de vez em quando nós
portistas digamos assim um nível mais
baixo e depois também em pike o que isso
quer dizer é quando surge uma situação
estressante nós e ao matias são digamos
assim do nosso sistema nervoso nós
também não somos tão alto e chegamos a
cinco anos
temos um caminho menos e recuperamos
mais rápido esse propósito engraçado nós
tipicamente conquistados no início nós
não temos noção disso então decidimos
fazer um mini e textos para brincadeira
no final da nossa próxima expiração vão
ser possível deixar os ombros diz que
iriam crimina houve muita sombra tática
aí é e tem a ver com isso não significa
nem notamos o campinense anos está
pronto
talvez a consequência mais importante
que venha vai do treino tático seja essa
gestão de mais clareza mental é a
capacidade deverá levar tal como ela se
apresenta e não como nós achamos através
de nossos filtros que é essa imagem que
eu gosto particularmente e ao todos nós
porque temos em comum que nós que
sejamos um soldado americano que enviar
para o iraque para combater o
equipamento em matar o inimigo que temos
uma pequena criança iac é que este
estranho na direção deu com a tão
estranho e estivemos a fazer uma
apresentação que estamos sentados ao
vídeo sentados ouvindo alguém conversar
sozinho no corpo em qualquer sítio do
mundo
ao todos nós precisamos motivação número
quase tudo que nós fazemos esse estava
em tudo aquilo que nós vamos fazendo
profissionalmente sou eu quem nos
relacionamos as atividades aplicamos
nosso tempo nosso curso tu tem na base
a ativação da mesma forma esta motivação
de um certo ponto de vista que irônico
que a forma como nós escolhemos um valor
acaba não funcionando muito bem
muitas vezes o que acontece é que nós
vemos a vida assim como estou tentando
transmitir etapa que por trazer uma
forma criar o caos em travar muito
preocupado eu me me próprios problemas
as minhas ansiedades as linhas e fica ao
lado e quanto mais eu faço isso mais uma
pequena pedra que possa cair nesse golpe
causou um grande esporte
quanto mais eu vou abrindo digamos assim
- um bingo todos à minha volta é
basicamente a analogia seria deixar
aquele mesmo pedro uma grande impacto
mas quase nada de ponteiras ivna desta
forma aos entrava em campo seria lógico
não faz sentido
quanto mais preocupado em ouvir que sou
minando mas qualquer coisa que aconteça
no meio ambiente estranho eu gostar e
quanto mais eu em com os outros mas
resolvi então vou treinando também aqui
que entra a idéia de cultivar o coração
nós também podemos treinar isto vamos
treinar intenções emoções com o
altruísmo e compaixão é só ensinar ou
estes anjos e que outras pessoas possam
estar online possam ter acesso ao
estágio no estágio em e as causas desse
estado e aquilo que está pra nós no
final devemos assim deste jeito e isso é
uma idéia de felicidade genuína e
cidades no iraque open de frança da
forma como nós tipicamente pensamos a
funcionar e que ela não tanto com texto
inteiro
no início ela forma como eu entrei e fiz
esse ano é da minha volta
quando falou sobre tite promoveu este
conceito com a idéia de uma harmonia uma
sociedade esperando que eu consigo
retirar do mundo que eu consigo é sentar
onde terminará em 30 segundos o que eu
queria mostrar foi uma é uma fotografia
eu tive a felicidade de passar é é
quatro meses em silêncio este ano é
fazer muitas dessas práticas nós temos a
discutir e esta é a vida que eu tenho
você tentava manter bastante é
conhecendo de poder praticar qualquer
das formas
eu queria só estávamos terminando com um
desafio que nos preocupar em não apostar
em quatro meses em silêncio
mas é simplesmente idéia de trazermos a
prática é que o treino do time até agora
não vou falar vocês acharam que algumas
das coisas que eu disse que fizeram
sentir
então meu desafio seria o primeiro tem
que cultivar a mente eo coração durante
10 minutos por vir todos os dias porque
cientistas e quando tiverem 7 então me
sim é chave para nós podemos esperar que
o estágio no entanto quanto stenning a
china forma como nós temos alunos
[Aplausos]